who makes our disk drive we were really
lucky when we started next in that we
got calls from the presidents of Sony
Motorola Canon and others and they said
hey when you guys were in your former
life time you used to romp through our
technology laboratories and you used
that spot technologies and help us form
them into marketable products and we
really like that cuz both of us won so
we'd like you to keep doing that and
we'd like you to keep doing that because
a maybe you'll be the next big computer
company and be because you're the
cheapest rnd we could ever do so we had
access to I think probably more of the
in-depth technical research going on at
some of these companies than most other
people I have the good fortune to have
we think more in terms of what impact is
this computer going to have on the
people that use it and so we are you
know much more about the industry than
we do at this point we're focusing on
the people that are gonna use this thing
and how to bring the most far-reaching
capabilities to them and so that's
that's where our focus is right now I am
exceptionally proud of the hundred and
seventy-five people that work it next
because they started without in some
cases when that when we started the
company of course we just started it
with a fresh sheet of paper and as
people have joined us over the months
and the years they have joined based on
not a product not even a description
they've joined on the vision University
what a degree
oh I don't know you mean the fact that I
don't have I'm a dropout um actually I
have a pretty fond sparked from spot for
higher ed in my heart I what happened
was I went to Reed College just like dr.
Richard Crandall
and I ran out of money after about six
months so I dropped out but they let me
drop in for about a year and a half
after that
and Stanford let me drop in for a year
and it's kind of something that's always
stuck with me I didn't have any money to
pay and they said fine just take the
classes and learn and that to me what is
what it's been all about so hopefully I
think
all of us you know feel really great
about being able to put something like
this back into that community and again
I can't stress enough this thing
wouldn't be here today if it were not
for our advisory board they have they
have led us into their research labs
they have let us hire their best grad
students and they have kicked us in the
pants when we wanted to compromise and
more than once matter of fact so if it
weren't for them this machine would be a
very different machine and I think all
of us at next feel an incredible debt to
them for hanging in there with us and
making sure this thing came out great
actually a very important decision it
next we said why should a student at
Reed College as small liberal arts
college with a thousand students or a
professor or researcher read have to pay
more for their computer than someone at
a very large institution let's say at
the University of California at Berkeley
and the answer is they shouldn't and so
we decided what's the best price we're
going to give to anybody and we said can
we architect our company in a way that
it doesn't cost us any more to sell one
computer than it does to sell a thousand
obviously we made some distance there
and we decided to offer our best price
to everybody so everybody gets the best
price and that's how we decided the
price it's very democratic and I think
it's in the spirit of what we're trying
to do with higher education thank you
very much for coming today we really
appreciate it a lot